question number 41 that is stephen
wolfram
asks is it true that we may have a
description
of how brains work slash process
language at a microscopic level
and we still may not have a satisfactory
science of linguistics that is
that the lower level doesn't necessarily
inform us about the
higher level well
first of all the idea of a description
of how
brains work at a microscopic level is
a dream people don't even know where to
look
so for example it's there's very good
arguments that
the computational work done by
the brain even in animals like instinct
insects is at the
probably at the cellular level even
internal to the cells
not at the neuronal level but
the fact of the matter is that if you
had
detailed information say about
cells or about atoms or
whatever would tell you very little
about the
way in which systems work
you could know everything about how the
atoms worked in a car and you wouldn't
know how the car works
that these are just at a different level
of organization